le 29 octobre 2018 un avion s'écrase
avec 189 personnes à bord en indonésie
quelques mois plus tard un deuxième
accident se produit un avion de la
compagnie ethiopian airlines s'écrase
avec 149 passagers et huit membres
d'équipage
dans les deux cas il s'agit du même
avion un boeing 737 max et ça n'a rien
d'une coïncidence
[Applaudissements]
on comprend l'une des raisons de ce
crash
il faut revenir un peu en arrière entre
2010 et 2011
airbus et boeing annonce chacun un
nouveau modèle ces deux avions
consommeront 15% de carburant en moins
chez airbus
il s'appellera l'a320 neo et chez boeing
le 737 max particularité de ces deux
modèles les moteurs sur les ailes sont
plus volumineux
[Musique]
lorsque le consortium general electric
safran un produit un moteur plus
performant moins gourmand alors airbus
après la version libre à et boeing la
version ligue b
[Musique]
cela ne pose pas de problème pour
l'avion d'airbus
cela va entraîner des changements pour
boeing car le 737 historique à ses
réacteurs plus proche du sol
il faudra donc les surélever pour le 737
max mais ce choix aura une conséquence
les commandes de vol électriques qui
permettent aux pilotes de contrôler la
viande avec un joystick et de piloter
l'avion le logiciel qui est établie tout
ça a dû être modifié et la modification
du logiciel a été rendue difficile parce
que avec ses nouveaux moteurs et cette
nouvelle aérodynamique de l'ale l'avion
avait tendance à décrocher les crocs
charge c'est quand la vie de l'avion va
pas assez vite quand on n'est pas assez
vite il tombe bring décide alors de
corriger ce problème avec un dispositif
matériel et logiciel ce système est
appelé le mcs
[Musique]
mais il va poser problème à son tour le
problème c'est que cette surcouche de
logiciels elle est alimentée par des
sondes
des capteurs y en a partout notamment
par des capteurs d'incidence il y en a
plusieurs dans l'avion mais il a qu'un
seul qui utilisaient si ce capteur tombe
en panne l'appareil revient à ces mots
originaux et se met à piquer il ya
également la question de la formation
des pilotes qui se posent lorsqu'un
nouvel avion sort ils doivent être
formés à son pilotage
l'a320neo étant quasiment similaire à
l'a320 airbus estime que ce n'est pas la
peine de faire une formation
supplémentaire
boeing avec son 737 max prend le même
parti pour rester compétitif alors
pourquoi ils ont fait ça ils ont fait ça
il ya plusieurs raisons possibles
la première raison c'est qu'ils sont de
bonne foi et qu'il dise attendait les
pilotes qui en a assez de procédures
d'investissement de donner toute façon
ça sert à rien de lui donner ces
informations
puisque si à une panne le système va se
reconfigurer tout seul et il s'en tire à
rien
l'autre raison c'est de dire que si le
constructeur ou lauren une certification
demande une formation supplémentaire ce
qu'on appelle un delta channing alors
les compagnies qui vont acheter cet
appareil vont être dans l'obligation de
demander aux pilotes de se former sous
un simulateur son envol et quand ces
pilotes vont se former son simulateur de
vol d'abord ça coûte cher
pendant ce temps là que je ne souhaite
pas l'appareil c'est pour ça que
certains pilotes ne connaissent même pas
l'existence du mcs
[Musique]
le 29 octobre 2018
l'avion de la lyonnaise quitte
l'aéroport de jakarta d'après les
premiers éléments de l'enquète le mcs
auraient été défaillants et l'avion
aurait commencé à piquer du nez pendant
de longues minutes le pilote va lutter
pour redresser l'appareil qui s'écrasera
finalement en mer de java
le mcs aurait également étaient
défectueuses lors du crash
ethiopian airlines du 10 mars 2019 mais
cette fois ci la cause est bien plus
grave
lorsqu'on a exploité la boîte noire du
vol d'ethiopian on s'est rendu compte
que la procédure de secours avait été
rigoureusement appliquée à trois
reprises et que l'appareil n'était pas
sorti du piquet et l'appareil s'est
crashé ethiopian quasiment à la
verticale
non seulement il ya un problème de
conception d'industriels qui a fait
quelque chose qui n'est pas acceptable
au plan de l'analyse de panne mais en
plus en plus l'autorité de régulation le
service des ministres préférés ne l'a
pas vu où la vue il a laissé passer et
ce qui est encore plus grave et le
troisième élément ce que je vais vous
dire c'est que la procédure de panne
pour que les pilotes sortent de cette
situation non seulement au début n'était
pas documenté mais quand elle a été
commentée est appliquée dans lequel
ethiopian n'a pas permis à l'appareil de
sortir de sa trajectoire
funeste et sa danse est roi c'est inédit
un problème de conception improbable de
cette situation et un problème de
procédure
c'est pas possible de faire pire au
total ces deux accidents auront fait 346
mortes et depuis ce deuxième crash tous
les 737 max sont cloués au sol
[Musique]